I've got a question for you
who are you
who do you think you are
for your dreamy for your running towards
your dream I applaud you for believing
in yourself because that's what life is
about stretching and challenging looking
for ways that you can begin to improve
yourself
and ladies and gentlemen as a result of
stretching out of acting on my dream and
I don't know what that dream is for you
I can tell you that it's possible Oh
will you give me what I want and I just
knew that I couldn't share that with him
because I thought that he would tear it
down break me break my dream so I kept
it in my heart and no matter what
happened to me in my life there was
something to look forward to if we're to
fulfill our potential we have to start
thinking differently we have to realize
that our we're not chained to our
current capabilities I'm sure you've
read or seen the quote shoot for the
moon because even if you miss your land
above the Stars let me share something
with you
it is something that's designed to
create a shift in your thinking it will
inspire you you'll create a motivational
environment for you or for someone you
care about it's good for children it's
good for adults it's good for you give
yourself the gift of motivation shoot
for the book that's what will challenge
you to do even if you miss you about
among the stuff because when you lose
sight or belief in yourself we're done
for I use the definition of
self-confidence to be the ability or the
belief to believe in yourself to come to
accomplish any task no matter the odds
no matter the difficulty no matter the
adversity the belief that you can
accomplish it self-confidence
the easiest way to build self-confidence
there's no magic button I can't say eh
this plane is going down who can fly it
put your hand up I can I'm confident
repetition repetition repetition right
what does Malcolm Gladwell call it the
10,000 hour rule there's no magic button
so let me ask a question what kind of
seed is in you
see I believe part of our
responsibilities in life is to find out
who we are to discover ourselves first
off we need to respect our nature we
need to realize we are part of a
continuing chain that carries a legacy
and a responsibility and if that's the
case then we need to recognize that we
were not biological coincidences magic
norm repetition repetition repetition
the problem is we expect to be
self-confident but we can't be unless
the skill or the task we're doing is not
novel is not new to us we want to be in
a situation where we created we've had
so much pressure in that and what I mean
because pressure builds diamonds we want
to be in the situation where hey have
done this a thousand times it's time to
reimagine your life it's time to
redefine yourself this is the moment you
reinvent yourself